my guest tonight is an emmy
award-winning comedian uh who spent a
lot of time
here at the largo theater her new
podcast is called confusingly
the sarah silverman podcast please
welcome in person
get out of my camera please welcome
i can't hiss anymore it's not covid safe
the hilarious sarah silverman
you're here thank you thank you so much
ah no seriously you are uh beloved and
then to be here in person
i was so happy to come to work today so
yeah i'm serious thank you for being
here this is a delight
can i have my shoes on this is that so
rude no no it's a problem this is no
this is hanging out at largo it's
jesus i'm surprised it's not covered in
[ __ ] already conan when are you going to
put on your show
outfit
it's so crazy that's why norman phil
yeah oh my god
my favorite thing is he'd say something
the cam yeah the camera's here
and he'd say he'd do a slam on jack like
yeah
you're such a fairy you could probably
float there and then
and he would look there for i don't know
30 seconds
loved it what a what a great man it's
almost what i just did to you
i mean reference almost but you
it was a little different when i first
of all thank you for saving largo
well you know someone someone had to
this theater was crumbling
falling apart and as we know this is one
of the favorite
theaters of all the comedy the cool
comedy people in
los angeles and run by a genius
we call them flanny flanagan yeah
flanny's been keeping the theater going
and we've been working with
this guy and man does he talk now
i'm highly suspicious of most of his
stories because they always involve
a very famous iconic rock star and it's
always like i was in a hot tub with bob
dylan
you're like what do you mean and then
you later find out that it's true he was
in a hot tub
or like um um bono in the ford focus
have you heard that one no he walked he
bono was here and he walked into his car
and he was driving a ford focus
and um they're so good and then yes i
had coffee with them yesterday
like we we sit in different we sit in a
four top on different sides you know
you sit in different restaurants yeah
and um
i'm sure this is true because it's
easily googleable and i was trying to
google it
and then i asked siri i had my glasses
on cut all this part out but
he said that mussolini in the end i know
he got
executed but he said they chopped his
head off and kicked his head around
through all the different towns like a
soccer ball and i just assumed it was
true and then this morning i
thought i wonder if that is true i don't
think that is true really
yeah i actually don't think that is true
and i happen to know a lot about
why does he make that [ __ ] up what they
really did to mussolini is good enough
they hung him upside down in a gas
station in milan
and pelted him with stones and then
kicked him for days and then stuffed him
in a coffin that was too small and
buried him
that's good enough yeah but they didn't
cut off his head and kick it around
throughout the different towns and it's
not
used regularly in soccer tournaments no
i heard i heard it went all the way down
italy until they kicked it off the tip
of the boot
the boot went yeah yeah
and mussolini went enough is enough um
i have to ask you about this it's i see
it every day i come here
it's a crocheted pillow with the face of
you
sarah silverman and it's here we've had
it steam cleaned
because well that's just what you do
with anything that's been sitting around
the largo
what is the story many people have sat
i'm sure it's covered in
fecal matter and like dried semen yeah i
mean it's a little distorted
well first of all why is there a
crocheted pillow with your face on it
here at largo
explain that needs an explanation yes it
does it does have an explanation
about five years ago i think um
i won't go into the whole story but i
like i almost died i remember this
randomly
you had a medical emergency yes yeah i
had like a
a thing a abscess on the top of my
windpipe it was either gonna
choke me to death or or poison me to
death if it exploded
you know like it's just one of those
crazy things at a surgery where they
told my
manager and my boyfriend at the time
like it was like 50 50 chance of
survival
but i i'm fine but i was like in a
induced
coma for a week and
my other friend named coco
mark coco cohen um
he didn't know what to do with himself
he felt so helpless
you know and he crochets
and uh as a matter of fact when he first
started crocheting he crocheted a huge
blanket and he
he was it like um he felt kind of
emasculated by the his new passion so he
wrote the word [ __ ] in the middle of it
just like a huge crochet anyway you know
grandma moses made a lot of those
yeah that's such a sweet look check out
look for that on uh on
etsy um but uh so so he
so he was so he didn't know what to do
with himself so he crocheted
a pillow with my face on it and then
when i got to the hospital he gave it to
me and it meant so much and because i
knew it just was
made with love and but then
you know i live in this little apartment
right and i go
right i was a flanagan i go i love mark
so much and i love that he made this but
i can't have a pillow of my face on it
in my
three-room apartment and um
he said bring it on down to i can't do
action bring it on down to the territory
we'll kick it around like a mussolini
head he said that's what everybody does
with the stuff that they they're too
embarrassed to have in their house so
like there's
you know there's like an oil painting of
zach galifianakis and a
jeff garland painting and like everyone
just kind of brings it inside
because they don't want to throw it out
but they can't have it in their home
right
if it means a great deal to you but you
want it to sit in an abandoned theater
bring it to largo i think that's a fiona
apple song
or it probably is it should be if it
isn't um listen we're all trying to get
through this
time right now as best we can i know
that this must be nice for you your
father
has moved much closer to you he lives
here in los angeles now doesn't he yeah
my dad and my stepmom janice that's cool
is it nice i mean you get to see your
dad all the time now and does he like it
here
he loves it it's so funny because i
never think of l.a as a city but he goes
i never lived in a city before you know
like
cause that's right because he was uh he
was in uh
new hampshire which there's no i mean
if you can get four trees together you
know like that's the city feel but
that's it
yeah did i ever tell you this one time
he goes when i first moved out here
this is just a boxton a boston accent
story but he goes where do you keep your
tax stuff and i go
i keep it in a drawer and then he makes
fun of me goes oh you keep it in a
drawer
you keep it in a drawer
[Music]
yeah how do you spell that
i go d-r-a-w-e-r he goes
he's [ __ ] me
[Laughter]
we no one can speak correctly and he
rides a little uh he's got a little um
like adult tricycle what you know
there's like adult tricycles
no i haven't seen that he won't get a
rascal
because that's what old people ride
right
he loves his triceps right he doesn't
want to be humiliated by riding a rascal
so he got a big tricycle yeah and
decorated
um you've said before that you enjoy
occasionally
uh smoking pot with your dad is that
still the case
i i we've smoked we just smoked on
saturday actually
after um we have every saturday
we have a um backyard you know we'll get
sandwiches or whatever and i've got
three sisters out here
their partners my dad my stepmom
and we are in the backyard and um
after dinner this time we passed around
to join it was good oh that's nice and
your dad your dad took a few puffs
yeah like a champ i mean it's crazy i he
barely even coughed
and then my stepmother doesn't like to
put smoke in her lungs
so rory my boyfriend
gave her uh rory's the new guy the
boyfriend cool
he gave janice a uh edible
and then we forgot about it then we're
sitting around he's got a fire pit
and he was sitting like here rory rory's
on the ground yeah he's like you know
we're just kind of running she's on a
chair and all of a sudden she
looks at rory and she goes are you
giving me a pedicure
and we just look at each other and we're
like oh yeah oh you forgot
it's it's starting to kick in it starts
she says the best
things when she's on an edible she'll go
like i can
feel my clothes
[Laughter]
let's talk about your podcast the sarah
silverman podcast congratulations you're
the perfect person to be doing a podcast
uh and i would just imagine you've got
such a funny creative
quick brain you know everybody you've
got a million stories
this is the perfect thing for you to be
doing right now thanks
well he said it all i want to thank
conan for being here
and for promoting uh my podcast the
sarah silverman podcast
do you like what are you finding that
you uh like most about doing it
i like just uh i like how
messy it is i like how loose it is
i just gab and then you know we i elicit
illicit is that the voice i don't you
have to say the whole sentence until i
can tell you if it's the right word or
not
i elicit voicemails from people
sure i would think it'd be maybe solicit
or i encourage
people to send in their voicemails
what's illicit well elicit like i elicit
a response
uh my my out my my outrageous remarks
elicited
strong condemn condemnation uh from the
politburo
what the hell was that mansplaining yeah
i'm sorry
no i asked you i know i love it when a
woman asks me a question and then i say
what i think it is and then they say
thanks for mansplaining
that's a good trap yeah i was trapping
you um
i i solicit you solicit
i don't think that's good on its own i
solicit i ask
for voicemails on my social media
streams
people call in and leave voicemails then
uh um
the producer diana listens to all of
them
picks about 20 or so and then the night
before we listen to it
and we pick about five or six and i
don't necessarily know exactly what i'll
say but i go yeah this will be good you
know
and then um usually i get in i talk
about whatever little micro
thing and then uh we play the
voicemails and that really dictates the
direction of the podcast
and then before you know it it's over
it's over and uh
what's nice is you're free of all this
strict professionalism of an interview
like this
it is funny though this is so
constraining let me ask you i want to
see the real you
not this uptight yeah rehearse this is
so rehearsed
when i i'm i maybe you
relate to this on anyway i don't know
when i started the podcast i thought you
know i've been
i knew it would be a learning curve it's
a new medium but
also i've been a public speaker for many
you know for decades now you know right
but it's
it's funny to me i had to learn a lot of
the stuff i learned in stand-up a long
time ago like
over again like the first few episodes i
said the f word
every other word whatever
right right i'm listening back and it's
like such
it's so bush league you know yeah and i
had to learn like all right i think i
was so excited about the total
freedom and you know it just comes off
like a crutch like you've got to make it
a treat or have a purpose for it or like
very decidedly no purpose for it
whatever but
you know i had to learn that again and
then also i was like why aren't people
writing
think pieces about this not that i was
saying that but you know what i mean
like i wanted like
and then i was in the tub but i took a
puff and i thought about it and i go
that's so embarrassing like
the one thing i tell young young
comedians like
don't look for an agent to come see you
right away or whatever just keep your
head down do stand up
and when you're good people will be
talking about you and i like it's like
in a pit
like this ridiculous epiphany that i
know better to just like
work do this podcast and work on it and
make it better each time i'm still
figuring it out
but here i am on conan just to get a few
more um subscribers what do you mean a
few more
you're gonna you're gonna triple your
numbers being on this show
a few more this is gonna put you through
the roof kid
strap in this is a rocket to success
this show i know as tigg says i think
i'm gonna
maybe i'll get discovered did she still
see
does tinotara still say that yeah maybe
i'll get discovered
because i think i'm gonna get discovered
tonight yeah
i don't think anyone's said that about
in show business in like 50 years
listen uh you're the perfect person to
be doing a podcast i'm excited that
you're doing this do you like doing the
ads
i do like doing the ads i don't know why
right i don't know what it is and maybe
it's like from listening to howard
or just listening to the podcast yeah
well he does he's the master
but also he you know howard stern i've
been listening to him for years
yeah and that it doesn't corrupt
his comedy or his point of view at all
he he'll he'll talk about whatever he
wants to talk about and he'll say
hey and by the way if you're looking for
window shades and i'll think yes
i am looking for window shades i know i
bought things from
i got two squatty potties for my dad on
father's day a few years ago
he was he was from he was pushing
squatty potties for a while
why two i don't know i just thought
does one go on top of the other is that
is that does that
move things along even faster if you add
more squatty potty like if you had five
squatty potties would you just empty
your bowels in a second
you know what i think i bought him two
because i do know that he only
he's designated one bathroom between the
two bathrooms they have
you know um for doing that but
um i think it's because it was nine
dollars and i felt cheap getting
one yeah but then it's just 18
right well i'm glad you know what you
just did now you worked in an ad for
squatty potty
that's true i wish we could show the
animation that explains exactly how it
works i like coming up with theme
songs i like you know what it's fun and
also i just think that like
when you're given limits there is
something about having no limits on your
podcast
so when you do have limits it forces you
to be creative like
like all the limits look at this look at
your audience that's what happens when
you have limits you come up with
weird creative comedy finds away stuff
exactly it's the limits that let us grow
yeah i mean just blue sky is like
paralyzing
exactly i think we've learned a lot in
this interview you want to have a
push-up contest i can only do one
i think i would win how many can you do
a lot more than one
a lot more well i'm a man aren't i
[Laughter]
well and also three is 300 of
one yeah so he's doing a triple i didn't
say that i would be
uh a functioning human being after i did
them
i mean we can't touch right because
another thing we could do is the three
of us could make a pyramid
can't do it people would write in and
say we'd get you know fouchy writing in
saying no pyramids
i said also because i'm scared i'm so
scared of getting it
i would i would in the pyramid thing i
would insist on being the top
i would insist on you being the top i
think thank you
you'd have to be the top about time
about time i got known as a top
well you know see this is the kind of
strict professionalism you need to
escape with the podcast
andy presents as a bottom but he's a top
thank you well anyway
welcome to things my parents won't
understand
you can listen to the sarah silverman
podcast on itunes and wherever podcasts
are available and you're going to listen
to it
i'm thrilled so delighted that you came
here in person that i was dancing in the
parking lot before you arrived here
thank you i'm so tired of zoom and i
love you and
you being here in person is just
christmas come early
i know that's a big holiday for you so
sarah silverman thank you very much
we're gonna say merry christmas again
yeah yeah every single year
look i'm kicking a mussolini's head i
kick a tear and i kick it